pour le maire de Mario Paul l'étendue
des massacres de civils seraient dix
fois pire qu'un bout de chat on en veut
pour il en veut pour preuve ces images
satellites de la société américaine
maxard peu après la victoire sur Mario
Paul revendiqué par Vladimir Poutine ce
jeudi l'entreprise a publié des photos
de ceux qui semblent être des fausses
communes près d'un cimetière de la ville
de manouche c'est seulement à 5 km de
Mario Paul le récit de Kevin Batista
manouche bourg ukrainien a une vingtaine
de kilomètres de Mario Paul sur ces
images satellites diffusées par une
entreprise américaine on distingue des
aménagements récents près du cimetière
municipal
l'entreprise affirme qu'il s'agit de
plus de 200 nouvelles tombes creusées
entre fin mars et début avril
se trouve un énorme fossé de 30 mètres
de long
et emmène nos citoyens là-bas dans
d'énormes camions tous ces citoyens sont
tués par la Fédération de Russie
selon les autorités locales jusqu'à 9000
corps de personnes tuées à Mario Paul
serait enterré dans ses tranchées
à Mario Paul lucrètent déplore plus de
20.000 morts plus de 100000 personnes
seraient toujours sur place et
subiraient les combats et les pénuries
ce jeudi quelques dizaines d'entre eux
ont pu être évacués par la Croix-Rouge
ça a été l'enfer pendant des jours et la
situation est critique c'est une ville
développée avec de bonnes
infrastructures et vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer à quoi ça ressemble maintenant
il n'y a plus rien plus que des ruines
Mario Paul a été déclaré ville libérée
par la Russie l'ultime poche de
résistance ukrainienne doit être assiégé
selon les ordres de Vladimir Poutine
quelques centaines de militaires sous
une usine métallurgique s'y trouve selon
Moscou d'après Kiev un millier de civils
Ukrainiens il serait également réfugiés